this is a very important video some
people some dumb balls still think the
earth is flat my god how can you be so
stupid
Logan Paul that's right disappointing
now let's look at this earth okay
what shape is this that's right round
but what a lot of people don't know is
if you keep zooming in over here over in
Canada over in st. Pierre Mickey aileron
over here at st. John over here at
Witness Bay we're getting closer over to
burned Cove over between the Great
Island and st. McHale
we have smash like on this video right
now if you want to visit peepee Island
cuz I don't know why you guys I really
want to go visit peepee Island what
happens in peepee Island I don't know
why does it have such an amazing name I
don't know either does this prove once
and for all that the earth is round I
think yes I wanted to explore a little
bit more here today well you can
discover on this amazing planet Earth
thanks to Google's technology with
Google Street View and Google satellite
there's so many different things to look
at so many things to appreciate so just
this new viral clip thanks to in I think
New Jersey or something like that we
have a Google Streetview of a man
falling down the stairs I shouldn't be
laughing at oh no oh oh god I haven't
seen the second one I hope he's okay I
genuinely do I see we can find this
alright let's add the little guy
oh no oh Jesus Christ they've lured him
out at least god I hope he's okay the
world is a wonderful place to live we
also have this incredible clip which I
think I've shown before a cute little
dog on another note just adorable little
dog chasing over the Google Street View
car the
[Music]
come on dog you can do it
some say the dog is still chasing the
Google Street View car to this day
- this thing just doesn't give up does
it
back at her hahaha I got you now
guru say Jesus Christ okay here we go
zoom in we're in Nihon Japan and
everyone
oh my god how did they know only in
Japan for those of you who haven't
visited Japan yes this is how everyone
walks around where did they go
[Music]
ah so creepy
goddamn pigeon people they are
everywhere take it back the earth is not
why does the Japanese earth look
different
okay explain this scientist huh oh yeah
I know this one okay so you look at the
speed limit
goddamn it Google look at the speed
limit 37 this is taken by the Google car
by the way
turn around here what is the speed limit
goddamn it Google all they blurted those
[ __ ] turn it
what the Freak Google you break the law
everyone tweet this out right now Google
break a lot I'm crying and I'm shaking
right now Google just confessed to this
horrific crime protip Google if you
break the law don't film it take it from
me who's never done anything illegal
moving on okay here's another coordinate
all right so you're just in a park it's
a nice day it's a nice weather
you're in co effin whatever that is you
walk down the street and boom it's a cow
incredible cows exist how did he get
past Vic Macau that is the real question
now that's some close-up action right
there thank you very much Google keep
shane dawson away from that it's not
even a joke Jesus Christ
All Right see you later cows you can
find all kinds of Google Streetview
why go outside when you can just click
through this look at this people looking
awkward but they always look at the
camera it's so creepy
okay one cool thing I actually found is
that is that you can actually go
underwater in a Google map like here
on-island you can go underwater and
there's a turtle pretty epic see
everyone looks into the camera this is
what I'm talking about
it's so weird damn that's epic look at
that amazing and we are killing it
congratulations everyone
alright next up I have some coordinates
that I want to explore where in the
world are we gonna go next that's right
everyone we enter the
for the nets we enter the satellite view
we zoom in on satellite view I assume
it's over here domain goddamnit and
there we have it a giant stuffed bunny
everyone giant stuffed bunny Thank You
Italy very cool we have this one if you
go to Google Earth type in the
coordinates blah blah blah it's a man
dragging a dead body to a lake
shocked face that is so creepy okay we
must investigate center the coordinate
their days where are they where did they
go hope the mysteries of life we will
explore this we will dig deep what
happened to this person it's a wet dog I
mean I should be happy I said I'll take
it panic averted I mean it looks crazy
alright so just another oh god Chad the
Magnificent country it even has the IE
my god Chad all hail Chad the greatest
country of all time
now if you zoom in a little bit outside
of Chad and you zoom in a little bit and
then just go and that's ever gonna write
the mouth well whatever it's lips very
fascinating the world is a magnificent
place prepared to be more fascination
upcoming here adding some more
coordinates beautiful people here we
have in hell is this pork Sudan ok you
zoom in enough in the Red Sea
bing-bam-boom
zoom time zoom time you can actually see
I think at least no supposed to be a
shipwreck god dammit
well that makes it lame we also have
this fantastic picture what the heck I
think this is in Mexico so creepy Jesus
Christ there's also there wonderful
places such as Chicago I don't know if
these are real I just love it so much
welcome to Chicago everyone but you can
also find arguably one of the greatest
thing on Google Streetview this dog
everyone look at this dog if this isn't
where smash like so
tribe I don't know what is incredible
good boy
meanwhile in Russia Google Streetview
what is happening here does anyone look
at it looking to like ah they got it
ah damn it Google streetcar goddess
there's also the I don't know what this
is I don't know what's happening here
but I can only imagine but they're
fighting us oh my god
they even convicted a man in Taiwan
thanks to Google Maps because an
Unleashed dog was responsible for a
neighbor's bicycle accident this is
Christ Google Mass will get you man big
brother is watching you but I think the
most the worst one is when he is falling
for no look at the poor dogs human falls
down oh no the poor dogs look at them I
stumbled upon this funny sequence
randomly who just randomly goes through
Google Street Jesus Christ take better
care of your dogs you dummy there's also
wonderful images such as baby being born
and naked man ain't sleeping trunk but
if you go to Gothenburg Sweden my
hometown you enter satellite view and
you zoom in just enough on stalled young
food living and you will find that's
right everyone represent calm /pd pine
t-series may have beaten us so you might
as well buy the 90 million club merch
because we sure as hell in getting
through to a hundred at this point so
thank you for your support and I really
really really really appreciate it and I
see you guys tomorrow bye
[Music]
what super simulators becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes this game is still relevant god damn
it
you